Speaker 1: All right, this next story.
At first, I wasn't going to cover it at all.
The story is that at an Atlanta Braves game
over the weekend at the World Series, Donald
Trump participated in the Tomahawk chop.
Now the Tomahawk Chop is this sort of ritual
or routine or, you know, I don't know what
you want to call it that is done at the Atlanta
Braves baseball games.
It also has been done elsewhere.
The Exeter Chiefs used the Tomahawk chop,
but it's quite well known for the Atlanta
Braves, and the idea is that it's sort of
a chopping motion done with your hand as if
you're holding an ax.
It's a reference to scalping by Native Americans
and what's problematic about it, you know,
every time sometimes it's like people play
really dumb.
They go, What's xenophobic or what's what?
You know, I don't know what the whether the
right worth is right word is xenophobic or
racist or whatever, but you're essentially
portraying as savages Native American peoples
in the United States.
And of course, the more we learn about native
populations, the more we learn that there
was quite a lot here.
They had complex societies.
They were developing technology.
You know, it's it's just ahistorical, but
it's also just really kind of vile.
And the story that first started floating
around was, Oh, Trump does the tomahawk chop?
And it's like, Yeah, whatever, Trump's an
idiot, I'm not going to cover it.
But then the storyline became that during
that, Melania Trump appears to turn away and
look disgusted and kind of roll her eyes at
Trump as all of this is going on.
And it's again this whole thing of, Oh, Melania's
being held captive.
Melania really hates Trump and all of this
sort of thing.
For me, the real story is that they were both
there doing the Tomahawk chop.
So let's start with the first video.
This is the Tomahawk chop taking place, and
both Melania and Trump are doing it.
If you can't see it, you're not missing that
much.
It's Trump and Melania doing the tomahawk
chop tape.
We take a look.
OK, so it's cringy, it's just it's just gross,
like it.
Oh, it's just what the hell is the former
president doing?
It's crazy that this is even done.
That's for me, the real story that Trump participated
in, that that was a blip.
But then the big story became this moment
that I'm playing for you here on repeat.
Melania smiles, and this was either, you know,
right before, right after the Tomahawk chop,
and she then just kind of grimaces and rolls
her eyes and turns away.
And it's again, this whole thing of Melania
doesn't like Donald Trump.
Is she safe?
Is she being held hostage if she's really
that disgusted with Trump?
She certainly hasn't shown disgust with the
specific ideas and xenophobia and backwards
thinking that Trump promulgated and emulated
during his presidency.
She would show up and talk about a lot of
the same things that Donald Trump did when
in her rare public appearances, there would
be some occasional little apparent disagreement.
But for me, the story here is not Oh, Melania's
discussed it again, and maybe she hates Trump.
Maybe she is.
And maybe that's true, but she's not acted
on it in any real way.
For me, the real story is the fact that the
president and the former president and the
former first lady are doing the Tomahawk chop
at a baseball game, which is just a horrible,
horrible again, just like a portrayal of of
of sap of unilateral savage savagery from
the very native populations that were decimated
by the arriving settlers of what is now the
United States.
So it's like the prototypical example of the
real story being being missed as what was
happening was was horrifying.
Just from Yahoo News, Melania Trump attended
a World Series baseball game.
Cameras showed her quick pivot from smiling
with her husband to turning away and rolling
her eyes.
Twitter also caught the moment, igniting discussion
on the platform Melania Trump strikes again.
It's pretty pathetic her.
Her strikes have been superficial in nature
and meaningless in substance, and that's really
the story here.
So if you disagree, if you think that her
reaction really is the big story versus the
fact that they were both participating in
the Tomahawk chop, let me know.
Let me know.
I'm open to being convinced.
But for me, the real story is the Tomahawk
chop